الان الى موجز الانباء على راس الساعه قال
مستشار لياء الرئيس الاوكراني لكيف لم
ترفض ابدا التفاوض مع روسيا داعيه القوات
الروسيه الى الانسحاب اولا من اوكرانيا
قبل الحديث عن التفاوض
واتهما مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني الرئيس
الروسي بانه غير مستعد للمفاوضات وان
اوكرانيا ستتحدث مع الرئيس الروسي القادم
ان روسيا لا تزال منفتحه على المحادثات مع
اوكرانيا
الصحيفه
ان محادثات السريه مع الجانب الروسي قال
انه وسائل الاعلام البريطانيه والامريكيه
توجد الكثير من ما وصفها بالمعلومات
الكاذبه
قالت الخارجيه الامريكيه الاتصال المستمر
مع الروس وان هناك قنوات للاتصال من بينها
السفاره الروسيه بواسطن وسفاره الولايات
المتحده
المتحدثه باسم البيت الابيض الى الولايات
المتحده اجرت في محادثات مع روسيا خلال
الاشهر الاخيره ركزت عن الحدين من المخاطر
تبدا والثلاثاء في الولايات المتحده
الانتخابات النصفيه للكونغرس الامريكي
وبينما يسع لحزب الديمقراطي اغلبيته في
مجلس النواب والشيوخ يتحرك الحزب الجمهوري
قضايا قضائيه لابطال الاف بطاقات التصويت
عبر البريد في ولايات
اقر رئيس ديني برجوجينا رجل الاعمال
الروسيه المقرب من الرئيس
ومؤسس مجموعه
تدخل في الانتخابات الامريكيه قال
بريكوجين لقد تدخلنا في الانتخابات
الامريكيه تدخلنا ومازلنا نتدخل سنواصل
التدخل
قالت وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه لاداره
الرئيس لن تتساهل مع التدخل في الانتخابات
الامريكيه بغض النظر عن مصدر ذلك
المتحدثه باسم البيت الابيض ان تصريحاته
اعلنا كوريا الشماليه انها سترد على
التدريبات المشتركه بين الولايات المتحده
وكوريا الجنوبيه
باجراءات العسكريه حازمه وتحدثت عن تنفيذ
طلاعات قتاليه شملت 500 طائره اجتها اتفقت
الولايات المتحده مع كوريا الجنوبيه
واليابان على توجيه رساله حاسمه وموحده
ردا على وصفت باستفزازات يونج
بزعامه رئيس الوزراء الباكستاني السابق
عمران خان المسيره الاحتجاجيه المتجهه الى
اسلام اباد في المطالبه انتخابات مبكرا من
اليوم الثلاثاء الى الخميس المقبل اغلقت
قوات الامن الباكستانيه لبعض الوقت
الطريقه الرئيسيه الذي يربط العاصمه اسلام
اباد ومدينه
كان عمرنا خان الطلبه رئيس الجمهوريه عارف
علاوي اتخاذ اجراءات تضمن تحقيق العداله
مضمنا رسالته تهديدات سابقه بالقتل
بجاتي قال وزير الداخليه الباكستانيه رنا
ثناء الله انه مستعد مع رئيس الوزراء
لمواجهه تحقيق في الاتهامات بضلوعهم في
محاوله اغتيال عمران خان معتبرا ان
التحقيقات سيكون فرصه لكشف الحقائق
الموجز في امريكا
[موسيقى]